or à mon sens les cahiers en avant sur
les terriens nous sommes de retour au
théâtre toujours en compagnie de daniel
auteuil
[Applaudissements]
de pascal de la tour du pin
et nous accueillons notre terriens du
samedi 20 heures pascal duquenne
accompagnée de sa mère huguette
[Applaudissements]
mais tu as des cheveux blancs
à locaux
il ya de ces mots
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir huguette bonsoir pascal
bonsoir alors il ya tout juste 20 ans
daniel votre tandem avec pascal le
huitième jour faisait chavirer le coeur
des français un film pour lequel vous
avez décroché tous les deux le prix
d'interprétation au festival de cannes
ce soir je vous propose de rembobiner
votre incroyable histoire
[Musique]
huguette et pascal re bonsoir
alors pascal vous êtes né le 8 août 1970
à vilvorde à 15 km de bruxelles perd
mécanographe à la sabena vous étiez
huguette institutrice en fait on vous
appelle mamy cacahuète vous adorez les
cacahuètes absolument c'est pour ça
alors à la naissance ce petit garçon aux
yeux [ __ ] huguette vous le baptisé mon
petit chinois c'est vrai qu'à l'époque
ya pas de diagnostic prénatal
et deux mois plus tard vous tombé des
nues lorsque le médecin vous annonce
madame votre fils et mongolien j'ai pris
ça comme on jette
comme une gifle
ouais c'est à dire je ne sais pas très
bien ce que c'est à l'époque
alors deuxième coup dur votre mari ne
supporte pas la naissance de pascal et
deux ans a pris part
mais là pour relever la tête
et puis enrico aussi c'est vrai que
enrico votre deuxième mari s'occupe des
enfants comme si c'étaient ses propres
enfants mes respects
pour mieux comprendre pascal à l'âge de
40 ans vous décidez huguette retourner
sur les bancs de la faculté pour étudier
la psychologie et pendant ce temps
enrico toujours lui s'occupe des gosses
un mec bien chapeau 1 et chapeau vous
captez mieux ses sentiments dites vous
après ses études de psychologie alors
pascal à l'époque vous tombez souvent
malades entre 0 et 10 ans vous ferez 25
séjour en clinique d'abord il ya la zone
et puis aussi vous êtes très fragile
c'est à dire qu'une piqûre de moustique
ou une piqûre de rose ça peut déclencher
chez vous une septicémie donc c'est très
compliqué évidemment pour vous j'imagine
mais pascal vous ne vous laissez jamais
abattre quand vous êtes en clinique vous
danser sur les tables
vous chanter à tue tête avec votre
tourne-disque et votre micro vous voulez
être le chouchou or vous avez envie de
vous exprimer comme ça mais à
l'adolescence vous le laissez très libre
votre enfant vous traversez bruxelles à
vélo pour retrouver votre mère à l'école
oui prenez des risques incroyable non un
jour vous passez sous un camion quand
même
métier drôlement inquiète 13 à 4 quand
je l'aï appris ouais ce que je n'y
attache pas mais tout le monde vous dit
le gars tu t'es folle de lui laisser
autant de liberté et vous vous pensez
que c'est bien pour le développement de
pascal que vous laissiez faire tout ça
cet alibi qui le voulaient ma mort je le
ferai plus je n'aurai plus d'accidents
mais je veux faire comme yves comme son
grand frère
alors vous poussez pascal vers la
natation vers l'athlétisme vers la danse
dans la musique l'équitation le ski et
même le théâtre
ou fait du théâtre depuis votre plus
tendre enfance vous avez commencé très
jeune non un cri très très très très
cher et 13 ans mais à saison pour la
première fois vous jouez devant 200
spectateurs
ça devient sérieux la mère est là
[Musique]
le destin dans la salle il y a la
première épouse de jaco van dormael
réalisateur belge oscarisé pour un court
métrage et vous voilà pris dans le film
toto le héros
gagnera une caméra d'or et un césar
dire que jaco van dormael il ya toujours
eu confiance en vous depuis le début
la connaît
ensuite c'est le huitième jour en labs
et inquiète quant à elle est choisie
pour la 8e journée
absolument j'ai trouvé le scénario trop
difficile pour pascal mais jacques on
disait j'aime en confiance d'avoir
confiance et vous pascal vous sentiez
bien de le faire
jamais eu peur peur vient mais jacquot
n'avait pas peur parce qu'elle n'avait
pas peur daniel quand on vous a dit que
vous alliez jouer avec pascal est ce que
vous avez eu peur non j'ai pas eu peur
et vous parler du spectacle je suis allé
voir ce spectacle et
et j'ai été sidéré c'est à dire que
c'était sur scène c'était des des
acteurs géniaux tous géniaux lui se
détacher il avait quelque chose en plus
au moment du salut j'avais l'impression
que c'était johnny hallyday qui veut des
sales usa se prenait à pied mortel à
venir étaient là à s'éclater et ensuite
comme je suis allé dans la loge j'avais
l'impression d'entrer dans une loge
d'acteurs à part entière nous les
houches chacun disait comment j'étais ce
oui mais voilà c'est c'est à dire que
c'est c'est un acteur génial
alors
ils vont trouver tous les deux sur le
plateau huitième jour alors au début
vous regardez un peu est-ce qui a brisé
la glace entre vous c'est une bataille
de boules de neige oui oui mais ce que
ce qu'ils étaient car les choses et
c'est arrivé qui c'est un acteur préféré
il disait toujours c'est gérard
depardieu
est sympathique
et ça le faisait beaucoup rire
la boule de neige oui boule de neige un
chez moi à la maison près en belgique
oui oui je suis j'ai une maison belgique
mais savais pas qu'on pouvait payer ses
efforts et ses impôts en belgique
le 20 mai 1996 c'est la remise des prix
du 49ème festival de cannes on regarde
[Musique]
le dow a été donnée après le décès de
daniel auteuil
pascal bastien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs du jury c'est
merci d'avoir supprimé la différence
c'est d'avoir fait de pascal un acteur à
part entière merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
oui
webb avait 5 ans
sans remonter les les escaliers on se
les marches là on se disait qu'on était
champion du monde on
m'a dit
champion du monde
guette c'est formidable pour vous tout
ce que vous avez donné à pascal comment
vous êtes occupé de lui la ssii pied
dans la saleté oui tout à fait ans au
real est heureux parce que je crois que
au début le producteur avait peur on
pouvait pas dire qu'il était trisomique
avant que ça se passe à cames je crois
quand même qu'il y avait une certaine
réticence à le dévoiler directement
parce qu'au fond c'était la toute
première fois
qu'à l'acteur trisomique
participe à quelque chose de grandiose
quoi c'est extraordinaire et ça restera
toujours toujours toujours la preuve
c'est comme en tant
que le film de jaco van dormael a changé
et qu'il n'y avait pas à l'époque c'est
le regard sur les trisomiques c'est à
dire que ça ça complètement les
mentalités ont évolué un sûr après ce
film alors le film fera 3 8 millions
d'entrées un succès extraordinaire
pascal quand vous l'avez vu vous êtes
dit est ce que c'est vrai ce que c'est
pas vrai cette histoire est voulue a été
obligée de lui dire non c'est du cinéma
bah oui ça vous a bouleversé de voir le
film
il ya des scènes quand il regarde pas ce
qu'ils regardent avec ses copains encore
régulièrement le huitième jour et à des
scènes où il est encore toujours ému
aussi tellement beau film est là pascal
devenu une star tient que vous
accompagnez le film dans sa tournée
mondiale vous allez au japon vous
découvrez le saké
vous avez aux usa aux usa s'appelle un
hibou la plage de malibu alerte à malibu
annonceurs se baladent partout dans le
monde comme ça en avion on va danser la
nuit à chicago interférer dans les
boîtes de nuit on a des interviews comme
ça avec toute la presse aux etats unis à
los angeles
il y avait 50 journalistes et puis il ya
un journaliste qui demande alors pascal
comment êtes vous avec les journalistes
comment alors i believe toi je t'aime
toi je t'aime toi j'ai ici des 50 je
tais toi je t'aime mais tous ensemble
non
et puis il ya une autre histoire aussi à
à los angeles
on présente le film cité du cinéma et
bien un journaliste qui ya une scène
dans le huitième jour où ils volent et
les journalistes qui lui dit mais
comment avez vous fait pascal pour voler
dans ce film et débat j'ai appris
[Applaudissements]
alors aujourd'hui pascal où il vivait
dans un appartement du centre ville de
bruxelles en parfaite autonomie grâce à
l'association huitième jour qui crée des
immeubles adapté c'est extraordinaire
c'est une greffe et ça évidemment c'est
en fait ce qui inquiète et un peu pascal
si dire quand mes parents vont
disparaître comme ma mère va disparaître
qu'est-ce que je qu'est ce que je vais
devenir je vais l'envoyer externe et
grâce ces appartements de l'association
du huitième jour d'un pascal peut vivre
normalement quoi tout à fait d'une façon
de tave autonome et on en a trente
maintenant sur quatre maisons c'est bien
on est occupé à créer une cinquième
maison maintenant pour ceux qui
vieilliront d une femme extraordinaire
ben non je ne bats pour mes enfants
alors pascal aujourd'hui âgé de 46 ans
vous continuer le cinéma le théâtre la
peinture la gravure et vous dites je ne
suis pas handicapé je suis trisomique
c'est pas la même chose
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus